halla dies wiedermal spanne und ich wäre
nicht ein riesengroßer weihnachts
fanatiker wenn ich nicht auch zum ersten
dezember ein video hochladen würde
und dann braucht zum thema weihnachten
ist doch klar ich weiß da draußen
menschen in den zauber von weihnachten
nicht verstehen darf aber schwer ist die
weihnachtszeit zu überleben ohne dass du
sie richtig verbringen zeit ein paar
tipps vorbereitet wie ihr es bis zum 24
dezember übersteht die zeit ohne
durchzudrehen
tipp nummer eins lieder mitsingt ja ich
weiß die kaufhäuser das radio alles
bombardiert uns mit diesen scheiß
weihnachtsliedern die man eigentlich
schon gar nicht mehr hören kann ich
spreche vor allem von last christmas und
jetzt fragt euch besser aber wie kann
man das denn überleben da sag ich euch
laut mitsingen denn wenn du laut
mitsingt verarscht du deinen kopf es ist
sie bei dem stock firma syndrom wo sich
die geisel in den geiselnehmer verliebt
warum verlieben wir uns nicht einfach in
last christmas
das kursmuster techno beats und erfunden
22 geschenk lässt euch so wie mir ergeht
dann müsst ihr ziemlich vielen leuten
geschenke machen
familie freunde nachbarn postboten di
luco logen und natürlich geht zunächst
gibt nicht zu viel geld dafür auch leibt
im bereich des möglichen dass heißt habt
ihr viel geld zur verfügung könnt ihr
mehr ausgeben wenn ihr aber nur ein
armer student sein oder ein schüler mit
nur 20 euro taschengeld
dann ist hier halt ein bisschen kopf
einschaltet das wichtigste dabei ist nur
besorgt es so früh wie möglich und damit
meine ich eigentlich die erste
dezemberwoche verpacken kann man sich
noch für später aufbewahren aber sie
müssen schon mal da sein und da mach ich
das so ich habe eine liste schreibe auf
wenig beschenken muss schreibe auch was
ich besorgen möchte
perfekt wenn ihr onlineshop der macht
sie sowieso das richtige denn dann habt
ihr den ganzen stress von euch keine
menschenmassen keine komischen
ausverkaufs orgien tipp3
weihnachtskarten schreiben es gibt leute
unter euch die nicht gerne
weihnachtskarten schrei ich denk mir
dabei immer wie sich die leute freuen
wenn sie diese weihnachtskarten heise
wenn ihr euren verwandten wirklich eine
freude machen wie zum beispiel den
großeltern die nicht dabei sein können
aus welchen gründen auch immer weil sie
einem anderen land leben oder
ja mein gehirn hat keine andere
möglichkeit warum großeltern ich dabei
sein können schreibt ihn eine
weihnachtskarte die werden sich so
freuen und am besten schreibt sie auch
so schnell wie ihr könnt und bewahrt sie
auf dass wir am ende das nur noch weg
schicken müsste ich mal so die schulzeit
angegangen wie ich weihnachten anlegern
wäre ich heute bestimmt arzt oder so
rechtsanwalt was sie noch gute berufe
keine ahnung youtuber mein nächster tipp
ist man allerdings ein tipp zur
weihnachtszeit denn tipp nummer vier
weihnachtsfilme schaue ich habe eine
luft ein weihnachtsfilm die ihr
unbedingt schauen ist wenn jede stimme
kommt denn danach hat ihr super in
stimmung für war noch das wunder von
manhattan
der polar express die geister die ich
rief kevin allein zu haus
liebe braucht keine ferien für die
romantische trauung versprochen ist
versprochen aber auch nur weil einem
schwarzen egal sagt peter drin ist
anastasia ein wunderbarer film täglich
grüßt das murmeltier nightmare before
christmas und wahrscheinlich jetzt auch
noch frozen denn da geht es um gefrorene
sachen manager- tier ist wohl der
wichtigste tipp nummer fünf essen und
schwitzen und dabei meine ich jetzt
nicht beim essen stützen sondern macht
viel sport zur weihnachtszeit ich sag
euch das nichts macht ein depressiver
wenn man über die wochenmärkten main
zone und aus essen verzichten kann man
auch nicht ich meine das essen züge zeit
ist so lecker diese ganzen brat saucen
und kekse und bratäpfel und
weihnachtsmarkt kann gibt müsse
ja ja weihnachtsmarkt kandierte müsse
darauf kannst du nicht verzichten
weshalb sport sport sport dass du
während der zeit viel sport macht und
dabei auch essen kann und wenn ihr diese
tipps befolgt dann wird es eine
wunderschöne weihnachtszeit verspreche
ich euch stelle nach heilige nacht
morgen kinder wird's was geben
bis 6